مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم في تغطيه
العربيه المستمره لتطورات الاثمه في
السودان ويسعد فريق الشارع الدبلوماسي ان
يشارك في هذه التغطيات من خلال لقائين
حصريين الاول مع السفير البريطانيه
المندوبه الدائمه للمملكه المتحده لدى
الامم المتحده وهي الدوله الحامله للقلم
في ملف السودان داخل مجلس الامن اما
اللقاء الحصري الثاني في سالكون مع الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو في اول لقاء
صحفي له منذاع منذ اندلاع قتال في السودان
في منتصف هذا الشهر
فسد بابره
الممثل الدائمه للمملكه المتحده لدى الامم
المتحده لدى الامم المتحده نرحب بكم في
العربيه شكرا جزيلا يسعدني ان اراكم اود
ان استهل الحديث عن الهدنه التي مدتها
اثنتين وسبعون ساعه نرى على شاشتنا تبادل
اطلاق النار وعمليات قصف المستمره ما هي
الاعمال التي ترسمونها بصفتكم عضو دائم
في مجلس الامن وحامل القلم بشان السودان
في مجلس الامن الاعمال التي يمكن ان
نرسمها بشان وقف اطلاق النار هذا ليكون
فعليا كما كنا نتابع منذ اسبوعين منذ
اندلاع العنف في السودان وفي الخرطوم على
وجه التحديد فقط قد راينا نفس الصوره
وسمعنا نفس الشهادات من الناس الذين علقوا
هناك ومن هؤلاء الذين ما يزالوا عالقين
والعدد
الوفيات بازدياد ويبعث على القلق والخوف
وكانت لدينا
محاولات متعدده
لابرامي هوجن على الارض لكن ما رايناه في
في لكن ما رايناه في اول هدنه لمده 72
ساعه كانت قد صمدت في الماء في اماكن اخرى
مما سمح للبعض للخروج والحصول على
امداداتهم الغذائيه واخرها كانت الهدنه
الاخيره كما قلت انها ليست هدنه مث
هجمات او عمليات قصف جوي لكننا لكن
نرى بان هذا تمديد للهدنه الاخيره
ونتطلع بان يتم التوصل الى مفاوضه سياسيه
وتسويه كما قلت المملكه المتحده هي حامل
القلم بشان السودان في مجلس الامن ما هي
السبل المتاحه لكم في المملكه المتحده
وبالنسبه للاعضاء الاخرين في مجلس الامن
من اجل الدفع باتجاه وقف وقف حقيقي لاطلاق
النار للحوار والعوده للسلام في السودان
والعوده الى
الى عمليه سلميه وحكومه مدنيه في السودان
كما قلتم اننا حامل القلم وهذا يعني باننا
نحن من نقوم بعقد
الاجتماعات وهذا كان من ضمن الاعمال التي
قمنا
باجراءها باصدار نشرات صحفيه والعمل على
التسويه والتوصل الى نشره وبيانات صحفيه
بالاجماع حول مساله ضروره التوصل الى وقف
اطلاق النار والعوده للمفاوضات قد اجرينا
اجتماعات عده في مجلس الامن منذ ذلك الحين
وكنا قد
قمنا باحاطه السيد فولكر الذي كان بنفسه
في الخرطوم وانتقل الى بورسودان
وبقي في السودان خلال عمليات انقاذ الحياه
وهذا عمل شجاع ومهم واجرينا مناقشه متعدده
في المجلس مع عدد من الاعضاء حول ما يجب
فعله في المرحله القادمه المهم
هو ان نقوم بان نقدم الدعم الكامل من قبل
المجلس فيما يتعلق بالمبادره التي تنبع من
اي جاد ومن الاتحاد الافريقي والدول
الاتحاد الاوروبيين من اجل التحرك نحو وقف
اطلاق كامل اطلاق النار وكما قلتم العوده
للعمليه السياسي اذا انتم سعداء لتلعبون
دورا ايجابي
والاتحاد الافريقي المنظمات الدوليه من
اجل حل
هذه المشكله وتصل الى حل سلمي ما نراه في
مجلس الامن في كافه الاوقات وخاصه عندما
نكون الدوله حملت القلم هو العلاقه بينما
يقوم به مجلس الامن والمنظمات الدوليه
الاخرى هي شراكه مهمه فمثلا في عملنا
بصوره اللاصقه بين مجلس الامن واسيا
واحيانا اخيرا
تتولى ذمه زمام المبادره والعكس وهذا
الامر ينطبق على السودان الامر الاهم هو
الوضع الانساني في السودان الذي يجب ان
يعيدنا الى الوضع السياسي وكيف يمكن لمجلس
ان يفعل ذلك يمكن من خلال العمل مع
الشركاء
الدوليين وكذلك مع القيادات في تلك
المنظمه الدولي
سمعنا كلنا السفير السودان السيد
الحارث ادريس الحارث
وما ذكره يوم الثلاثاء وهذا ليس بامر خافي
على الجميع بان السودان لا يرغبون من
الامم المتحده او مجلس الامن ان يلعب حل
رياضه في حل الازمه في السودان بل يفضلون
بحل هذه المشكله داخليا او من خلال منظمه
دوليه مثل او الاتحاد الافريقي
الذي يمكنه ان يلعب دور وساطه لحل لحل هذا
الصراع كيف تساعدون دوله ما التي لا ترغب
بمساعدتكم او
وساطاتكم الحميده لنزع فتيل الصراع اولا
كنت اتحدث بصوره لسيقه مع السفير خلال
فتره الصراع وكما قلت بان المملكه المتحده
هي حامله القلم ونحن ننظر الى مساله
السودان بسوره المثيقه من اجل مساعده
السودان وهذا امر عكفنا على فعله منذ 20
عاما
نرغب باستقرار الامور هناك كيف يمكن
مساعده السودان الامر الاول الذي يجب فعله
هو تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه ونحن في
المملكه المتحده نقوم بذلك بصوره ثنائيه
من خلال تقديم ما يزيد عن 250 مليون باوند
وتقديمها الى الاشخاص الذين هم بامس
الحاجه للمساعدات الانسانيه وكانت الامم
المتحده تعمل على تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه حالها حال منظمات الانسانيه
الاخرى ومن ثم الامر الاخر الذي نواده
بفعله هو ان نعود للعمليه السياسيه وهنا
بطبيعه الحال يوجد دورا مهم
للممثل الخاص
للامير المتحده السيد فولكرسيس الذي هو
على اتصال مع الجنرال برهان والجنر
الحميدي وجهات فاعله اخرى واعلموا ان وزير
خارجي ووزير الدفاع البريطانيين كان على
اتصال مع برهان الجنرال برهان والجنر
الحميدي وما بعض القاده الاخرين في
المنطقه
وكذلك مع بعض المنظمات مثل الاتحاد
الافريقي ودول الكليه يحاول يلعب دورا مهم
في هذه الظروف الصعبه من اجل صمود وقف
اطلاق النار ومن بعدها يمكن استئناف
العمليه السياسيه هؤلاء الشعوب في السودان
يرغبون بان يحضروا بالمستقبل
لنفسهم هناك هناك تصريح صدر من قبل
السفاره الامريكيه في ليبيا يذكر بان
بربره ليف مساعده وزير الخارجيه
لشؤوني الشرق الادنى قد بانها قد تحدثت
الى الجنرال خليفه حفتر قائد الجيش الوطني
الليبي عبرت فيها عن مخاوفها وتشددت على
ان هناك حاجه لمنع الكائنات الاجنبيه بما
في ذلك مجموعه من العمل على عدم زياده
زعزعه الاستقرار هناك او في دول الجوار
مثل سودان هل ترينا ان مثل هذا التصريح قد
يدفع الى كل تلك المخاوف نعم
نعلم كلنا ان مجموعه كانت تعمل في السودان
وكذلك الحال في ليبيا ومالي واماكن اخرى
وفي كل مكان تتوجه اليه مجموعه
وهي ذراع للحكومه الروسيه
تعمل على
على اعاده الفساد وخاصه في ظل الظروف
الاقتصاديه ونحن لا نرغب بوجودها في
السودان وايضا هناك نقطه اكبر السودان هي
بلاد كبيره
ولديها مساحات شاسعه
البعض منها ان يعيش حاله من عدم الاستقرار
ولا نرغبه ان تنتشر هذه الازمه وتتسع
رقبته
المملكه المتحده
حالها حاله دول اخرى قامت باجلاء بعض
المواطنين من السودان لكن هناك
هناك البعض الذين يرون بان
الاسره الدوليه قد يئست من ايجاد حل
للسودان ماذا تقول لنا
نعم صحيح باننا قدمنا عمليات اجلاء
للمواطنين الذين كانوا يرغبون بالخروج
اكثر من
[موسيقى]
1500 شخص وكذلك دول اخرى تقوم
عشرين على عمتنا عشرين رحله نعم نعم مع
نهايه اليوم نكون قد وصلنا الى 20 رحله
لكن بالنسبه للتخلي عن الشعب السوداني
فهذا غير صحيح اعلم ان
العاملين في المجال الانساني وتقديم
المساعده الانسانيه لا يزالون في السودان
وكان وكان
الامين العام واضحا في موقفه بان الامم
المتحده لن تغادر السودان وكنا قد تحدثنا
الى بوركرتيس المبعوث الخاص للامير العام
وهو لا يزال في السدد لذا فان الاوليات
القصوى الان هي تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
والمساعدات الطبيه للالاف الذين جرحوا في
عمليات القتال والصراع وتقديم
المواد المنقذه للحياه بصوره اساسيه
والعمل
مع القوات السودانيه لاعاده
مع الاطراف المصارعه لاعادتها الى المسار
الصحيح هل يوجد للمملكه المتحده اي خطط
لاعاده توطين هؤلاء الذين فروا من السودان
بالنسبه لهؤلاء الاشخاص الذين تم اجلاؤهم
هم مواطنون بريطانيون
وعدوا الى وطنهم تذكروا ان السودان هي
بلاد كبيره كما اسلفت الذكر وهؤلاء الذين
يفرون بحاجه لمساعده مباشره
ولا يتوجب عليهم ان يقوموا بالتوجه برحله
طويله من اجل الوصول لبر الامان في
المنطقه بما في ذلك في الدول المجاوره
للسودان التي تعاني ما تعانيه من تلقي
اعداد واستقبال اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين
وتقديم الدعم لهم سواء لكن هناك حاجه ماسه
لدعمها هؤلاء الذي سواء كانوا في السودان
في الدول الاخرى السؤال الاخير
لقد نقلت المملكه المتحده
سفرتها من الخرطوم الى اديس ابابا مره
اخرى مر رساله الذي تحملها هذه العمليه
بالنسبه للسوداني لدينا تهديدات محدده قد
طالت موظفين في السفاره ولذا قمنا بنقل
السفاره الى اديس ابابا بحيث تستطيع العمل
بطريقه امنه ويمكن تامين الماء والكهرباء
ومن اجل استمرار عمل السفاره بطريقه
الامنه وكذلك
ونقل عمليات السفاره في اديس ابابا سوف
نركز على الشعب السوداني والتوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار والعوده للعمليه السياسيه
السفيره
الممثله الدائمه للمملكه المتحده لدى
الامم المتحده نشكركي على هذه المقابله
وعلى
وقت شكرا جزيلا الى دبي حيث نستمر في
تغطيه احداث السودان
وسنلقاكم بعد قليل في الشارع الدبلوماسي
في لقاء حصري هو الاول للامير العام
انطونيو منذ اندلاع الازمه السودانيه فلا
تذهبوا بعيدا
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم ثانيه
يسعدنا الان نستضيف حصريا الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو في اول لقاء له حول
السودان منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل الجاري
ليسونيا
نرحب بكم في قناه العربي انه من دواعي
سرور
واسمح لي قبل ان نبدا
ابعث برساله الى الشعب السوداني
لكل هؤلاء السودانيين الذين يستمعون لي
اود ان اعبر عن تضامن العميق وتضامن الامم
المتحده العميق عندما كنت المفاوض الاعلى
للاجئين زرت السودان عده مرات وكنت دائما
مندهشا بحسن الضيافه والكرم في الشعب
السودان كنا نرى اللاجئين من اريتيريا
واحيانا يشاطرنهم توفر لديهم من موارد من
خلال نظام يعتمد على الاخويه نظام رائع
ولرؤيه هذا الشعب الشجاع هذا الشعب السخي
يعاني بهذا القدر كما نراه اليوم هذا امر
يبعث على الصدمه ويزعجني للغايه
وهناك كميه جمله من الامور التي يجب ان
نقدم
نقدمها فالامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن
السودان وسوف تفعل كل ما بوسع من اجل
تامين الظروف الامنيه من اجل تقديم الدعم
الانساني للشعب السوداني وكذلك ايضا
المفوضيه العليا لشؤون اللاجئين والتي
عملت بها لمده عقد من الزمن هي فاعله في
هناك وسوف تضمن بان اللاجئين الذين يعبرون
سوف يتم استقبالهم بطريقه مكرمه وهذا صراع
اود منه ان ينتهي وسوف نفعل كل ما بوسنا
من اجل توصل الوقف دائما لاطلاق النار
وللسودان ليعود للحوار
والتوصل الى حاله من الاستقرار وتمهيد
الطريق لانتقال ديمقراطي فشعب السوداني
كان يحارب من اجل هذا المغرب شكرا سعاده
الامين العام نثمن هذه الكلمات من المؤكد
ان الشعب السوداني ايضا يثمن ما قلتموه
تماما
الساعات الاثنتين وسبعين
الخاصه بالهدنه لم تصمد نرى عمليه قصف جوي
وبري
الى اين نحن ذاهبون نعلم بانكم اتيتم
مباشره من المطار الى الاستديو الخاص بنا
بعد وصولكم من واشنطن العاصمه
ونشكركم على هذا الجهد لكن هل هناك اي
افكار لديكم في حاله عدم صمودي تلك الهدن
بصوره مستمره فنحن لم يعد لدينا الم يعد
لدينا اي امل بالحوار والعوده للعمليه
الديمقراطيه لتوصل لاقامه حكومه مدنيه هو
انني
سمعناه وكنا جميعا بما في ذلك الشعب
السوداني الذي سمع لك كله يطالب
بالتواصل لحكومه المدنيه كيف يمكننا ان
نقنع الاطراف المتصارعه بان هذه هذا البلد
هو بلدهم وانه لابد من وقف القتال
انه ليس بسؤال بسيط
هذه هي الهدنه الثالثه على مر الساعات
الاثنتين الماضيه
الاولى
والاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد وهي منظمه
اقليميه افريقيه في المنطقه وجامعه الدول
العربيه كنا كل نهيب بوقف اطلاق النار
لكن لكن
رغم التوقف القتال وتيره القتال قليلا
لكنها لم تصمد وبعد ذلك
تم استئناف القتال ولم تصمد الهدنه
اذا كان هناك اي امكانيه للتوصل الى
واعاده نقل
لموظفين الامم المتحده فكما تعلمون اكثر
من الف ومائتين موظف من الامم المتحده قد
تم نقلهم عبر السودان واود ان اشكر
الاطراف لانني كنت قد تحدثت
معهم
لكن للاسفيه يبقى القطاع المستمرا مع هذه
الهدنه الاخيره اعتقد انه يجب علينا ان
نتحد كاسره دوليه وان نعمل مع الاتحاد مع
الاتحاد الافريقي
والعمل مع الايجاد ورئيس كينيا
ورئيس جيبوتي كلهم مستعدون للتوجه للسودان
واعتقد بانه يجب فعل كل شيء من اجل خلط
الظروف المئاتيه من اجل تحويل الامور الى
اسواق والتحدث الى الجنرال برهان والجنر
حميتي والتحدث الى اطراف الاخرى هذه ليست
فقط مساله جنرال فحسب بل مساله الشعب شعب
بقياده سياسيه مدنيه شعب من جيل الشباب
والنساء من الصعب
على هذه الشاكله لذا لابد لنا ان نعمل على
تسهيل هذه المهمه بالنسبه لرؤساء الدول
الافريقيه ثلاثه اذا ما كانوا بمقدورهم
التوصل للاتفاق الاطراف المتحاربه لان
الاتصال المباشر بين الناس هو الاكثر
فعاليه من اجل التغلب وتدليل الظروف ادرى
مسيكيه والعقبات كذلك نشهد
عمليات القصف للاسف لا تزال مستمره واناس
يقتلون ومعاناه لا توصف والسودان كما
تعلمون يعاني من ظروف اقتصاديه هشه وهناك
مشاكل انسانيه كبيره
ومشاكل امنيه ملحمه لذا
هذا الامر غير مقبول
او حق يدفع لهم ان يقوموا بالقتال من اجل
السلطه ما الذي
يوقف
اليه الثلاثيه لهؤلاء الرؤساء الثلاثه
ان المطار الخرطوم لا يعمل لكن كنا قد
راينا طائرات تقوم باجراء عمليات الاجلاء
لماذا لا يتوجهون اليوم الى السودان
انا متاكد تماما بانهم سوف يتوجهون باسرع
ما يمكن له هناك وكنت على اتصال مع
رئيسه شاهد نعلم بان هناك الظروف الامنيه
هي بالحد الادنى لكنهم يرغبون بالتوجه الى
هناك بدعم كامل من الاتحاد الافريقي
وجامعه الدول العربيه والامم المتحده
ولابد لنا ان نجرب هذين الطرفين
المتصارعين للحوار وحتى الان لا يوجد اي
اتصال حقيقي بين الجنرلين لا بد لهم من
التحدث مع بعضهم البعض في
هناك في
في مواقعهم من اجل حثهم على التواصل
الاتفاق والسماحي لكل امر اخر ان ياخذ
مجرى وكما قلتم بان هناك
مجموعه كبيره من الجهات الفاعله في
السودان التي يجب اشراكها من اجل التوصل
للحل
لقد تحدثتم في اكثر من مناسبه مع الجنرال
البرهان
ومع الجنر الحميتي
قائد
القوات الدعم السريعين هل هم على استعداد
لاستقباله الرؤساء الثلاثه من الافريقيين
هل هم على استعداد لذلك اعتقد انهم انهما
كذلك
لابد لي ان اقول بانني كلما تحدثت الى
هذين الجنرلين كان يقولان بانه ما يرغب
بالتواصل لوقف اطلاق النار وكلهم منه ما
كان يلقي بالتهم على الطرف الاخر لعدم
صمودي
الهدن لكن في
هذه اللحظات لابد لنا ان نقول ان القتال
لن ياخذنا الى اي مكان
واستمراره كذلك الحال انظر ما الذي يحدث
في الخرطوم وفي دارسه انه امر مؤسف
المجتمع ينهار
حتى القبائل تسعى لتسليح انفسهم
يؤدي الى تفتيت السودان هذا هذا القائدان
اذا يجب عليهما التحلي بالمسؤولي اخلاقيه
من اجل عدم تدمير بلديهما وتدمير وحدتي
واستقراري بلدهم
والمخاطر الان باتت مرتفعه
وهناك خشيه من شردمه البلاد ووجود صراع
عرقي قد يندلع
على مستويات كبيره
ايضا هي بلد لديها
مشاكل
على مقربه من السودان
وتذكر انها عمليات الانقلاب كانت ناجحه في
السودان وكلها نبعث المقام الاول من
دارفور
واثيوبيا ايضا
تعيش في مرحله التعافي في عقب الاتفاق بين
الحكومه
قوات المعارضه
مره اخرى بلد يعاني من اجل التوصل الى
السلام لذا
السودان حتى اللحظه لم يتحد في كافه
المكونات وانني اخشى من التدخل المحتمل
لبعض القراصنه الموجودين في ليبيا
تعني مجموعه الكل
الجميع انه انا اهيب بشده بعدم التدخل
بشؤون السودان من قبل
انه من الضروره بمكان
بانه
لا يجب التاثير على هذه الازمه المتفاقمه
سلفا في السودان وكذلك ارتيريا لديها
علاقات معقده مع السودان في السابق هو مصر
هي الاخرى
ميليتاريها بعض القوات العسكريه المتواجده
هناك
في فتره ما كل هذه الدول ترغب بالسودان
امن دوله مجاوره امنه زعيم
مجموعه
فاغنرال باننا نحن نرغب باحلال السلام
بينما الامم المتحده ترغب باراحه الدمى ما
الذي ترونه من هذا التعليق اعتقد ان هذا
هراء محض
ولن اعلق عليه اود ان اسالكم عن عن مبادره
الايجاد
للمحادثات في جوبا وكان هناك حديث حول عن
عن ارسال
الجنرال الكباشي الذي يمثل الجنرال
البرهان لبدء في هذه المحادثه المحادثات
ما الذي جرى بهذا الخصوص لا توجد لدي
معلومات لكن
لابد لي ان اقول بان الوساطه الافريقيه في
الازمات الافريقيه لطالما كانت ناجحه في
السودان في السابق
فالاتفاق كما تعلمون كان قد تم قد تمت
رعايتهم من قبل الاتحاد الافريقي وفي
اثيوبيا كذلك الاتفاقيه التي تمت تاسيسها
ايضا من خلال ثلاثه شخصيات
في جنوب افريقيا
والرئيس كنياته الذي لعب دورا مهما في جمع
الاطراف المختلفه
وفي انغولا ايضا
كانت هناك قدره ناجحه للقاده الافريقيين
لمعالجه الصراعات المعقده وامل ان يحدث
ذلك هو اراهم انهم في موضع افضل للتوصل
لاتفاقا في السودان لا شكل لدي بانه قد
يكون الامر اكثر سهوله للجنرات السودانيين
للاصغاء لزملائهم الافريقيين بدلا من
الاستماع الى الامريكيين او الاوروبيين او
غيرهم لذا فان مناشدتي
كل شيء من اجل دعم مبادره يقودها الاتحاد
الا فريقي
التي تفضي الى احلال السلام
الى الممثل الدائم السفير السوداني لدى
الامم المتحده السفير الحارس ادريس وكان
قد تحدث امام مجلس الامن يوم الاثنين في
جلسه خاصه حول السودان وكان من الواضح
بانه لا يرغب بمجلس الامن ان يقوم باتخاذ
اي دور او تصاريح او عقد اجتماعات من قبل
الامم المتحده حول السودان
وكذلك ايضا لا يرغب من جامعه الدول
العربيه ان تلعب دورا في الصراع في
السودان يرغبون بحل هذه المشكله على
المستوى الداخلي وهذا يبدو ضربا من
المستحيل هل هناك
مبادره من ايجاد او الاتحاد الافريقيه هل
الامم المتحده سعيده لتلعب دورا ثانويا مع
الايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي من اجل التوصل
الى حل
لطالما دافعت وقلت بان الطريقه المثلى لحل
المشاكل في افريقيا يجب ان تنبع من وسطات
بقيادات افريقيه والامم المتحده بدورها
مستعدا لدعم ايجاد في هذه الجهود جهود
الوساطه
من المنطقي
ان نتباهى في امور قد لا نستطيع فعلها
لابد من تنفيذ الامور بالطريقه الصحيحه من
خلال مؤسسات الافريقيه هو اعتقد انه من
واجب الجميع وواجب مجلس الامن يفعل كل ما
بوزعه من اجل دعم مبادره بقياده افريقيه
لحل الصراع في السودان
قلتم وانا اقتبس هنا ان هذا الصراع يخاطر
يهدد
بامتدادي بقعه الصراع في السودان الامر
الذي قد يطال المنطقه وما بعدها الى اي حد
هذا امر وقيل وقد راينا اعدادا من
اللاجئين يفرون من السودان الى تشاد
واثيوبيا ومصر
[موسيقى]
وحتى الى جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
الصراع في دارفور
يشكل دائما تهديدا
للاستقرار والامل في تشادر من خلال
تجاربنا في السابق نعلمه
انه كان هناك علاقه
بين هاتين المنطقتين من خلال الحدود وهذه
مساله حساسه
جنوب السودان لديه مشاكل لم تحل حتى
اللحظه في السودان مثلا لدى من الضروري
بكل تاكيد ان يتم تفادي اي نوع قد يدفع
لحاله عدم الاستقرار قد يطال دول الجوار
اود ان انتقل الى الجانب الانساني
على جمله من التغريدات التي قمتم بنشرها
عمليات الاجلاء والتي شكرتم بها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي قامت بدور فاعل في
اجلائي موظفين من الامم المتحده من
السودان هل انتم مستمرون
باجلاء العاملين في المنظمات الانسانيه
واسرهم بل سوف تبقى البعض سوف سوف نلقي
كافه الموظفين الوطنيين
والموظفين الاساسيين وسوف نعمل على خلق
مركز جديد في بورس السودان بحيث يكون لديه
القدره لتقديم المساعدات داخل البلاد لان
بورسودان في وطن امن كما تعلمون
وما فعلناه كان هو عمليات اجلاء للموظفين
غير الاساسيين واسرهم وكذلك ايضا فعلنا
هذا الامر مع كافه المنظمات الاخرى غير
الحكوميه
والبعثات الاخرى وكان هناك قافله التي
قامت بنقل اكثر من 200 موظفه وقود اشكرك
كل من ساعد في هذه الجهود فكانت هناك
فرقاطه فرنسيه
قد جلبت هؤلاء الاشخاص من جنوب السودان من
بورسودان الى جده
وكانت هناك مخاوف في منطقه الفاشر حيث تم
نقل لاناس من هناك الى تشاد وكان التعاون
ملموسا من قبل اطراف عده ودول في المنطقه
وجهه الامنيه وكنت قد اتيت من واشنطن
وعلمتم
برغبتهم بتقديم المساعدات فضلا عن الشكر
الذي يجب ان نوجه الى اطراف اخرى هناك
شعور
كبير بالتضامن وانني ممتن لكل هذه الاطراف
التي تقوم باستقبال اللاجئين من السودان
خلال هذه الفتره
ونامل انها سوف تكون فتره اللجوء القصيره
وسوف تكون لهم فتره فرصه العوده لكن هناك
حس كبير بالتضامن اعتقد بانه لابد لنا ان
ندرك
بان هذا التضامن الدولي كان ملموسا وفي
هذا السياق الجنرال برهان والجنرال
الحميدي كان ايجابيان في مساعدتنا في
تنفيذ عمليات الاجلاء بسلامه
هل لديكم اي خطه طارئه
لمساعده ملايين السودانيين الذين هم بامسي
الحاجه
للمساعدات الانسانيه والمساعده المنقذه
للحياه
اذا ما كان هناك وقف حقيقي لاطلاق النار
نعم لدينا خطه طوارئ
ومستعدون لتعزيز قدراتنا هناك لكن يجدر بي
ان اقول باننا
قد اخذنا على حين غره فنحن لم نتوقع
اندلاعي هذا الصراع بتلك الطريقه وما من
شخص اخر توقع حدوثه حتى قبل يوما من
اندلاعي الصراع
ان الامور سوف تخرج عن مسارها العاديه
وانا لابد لي ان اسالك وان اسال عن نفسي
لماذا تحدث هذه الامور ولماذا حدثت فجاه
واطرح هذا السؤال على نفسه اذا ما كان
الامر كان خارج نطاق الطرفين المتصارعين
وقد تكون هناك اطراف خارجيه التي تحفز
وتؤجج من اجل هذا الصراع لاننا كنا قد
وصلنا الى مرحله مفصليه للتوصل لاتفاق
ياخذنا الى حكومه ديمقراطيه مدنيه لذا
المساله قد تكون ليست فقط مساله بين جنرال
على السلطه بل هناك بعض الاطراف الاخرى
المهتمه
بهذا الامر هذه المره الاولى التي اراك
فيها تظهر بعض الشكوك اقول بانه قد يكون
هناك بعض
قد تكون هناك بعض الجهات التي تستغل هذا
الموقع
سوف تدفعني للتكهن هل لك ان تقول لي من
سوف القيك في حاله
لكن هذه افكاري
وكنت قد اجريت مناقشاتني مع جمله من الدول
مع دوله الامارات ومن المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
لاننا كلنا
صدمنا واخذنا على حين غره في اللحظه التي
اندلع فيها هذا الصرع وان نعلم بان كانت
هناك درجه من التوتر في ظل وجود بلد لديه
جيشين لديه جيشان جيش نظامي
قوات عسكريه شبه النظاميه يجب ان تتحد وان
تندمج نعلم ان الجنر البرهان كان يرغب
بتوحيد
هذه القوات خلال السنه خلال سنتين الجنر
الحميدي خلال عشره سنوات هذه مساله كانت
ايضا نقاش وما من سبب
للتدهور الامور واندلاعها الى حرب مدنيه
كما راينا اود ان انتهز هذه الفرصه
واقدم التعازي الحاره لكم بوفاه
الموظفين الخمسه من الامم المتحده
من منظمه الهجره الدوليه وبرنامج الغذاء
العالمي في السودان الذين كانوا يساعدون
الشعب السوداني
المستودعات الخاصه
ببرنامج الغذاء العالمي قد تم نهبها
وتم نهب المؤن
ما الذي سوف تفعلونه الان من اجل
تاميني امدادات جديده لاننا لاننا بحاجه
الى اننا بحاجه الى مستودعات اولا
[موسيقى]
بحاجه لامن لحتى يتسنى للقافلات من التحرك
وكما قلت باننا قمنا باقامه مركزا في بورس
السودان من اجل اقامه الظروف الامنيه
المؤثيه لضمان الامدادات المطلوبه للمناطق
السودانيه المختلفه التي هي بحاجه
ويجب ان يكون لها قدره التحرك من تشاد ومن
دول المجاوره اخرى وهذا الامر كله يتوقف
على تطور الصراع اين سوف تكون طرقات التي
يمكن استخدامها هذه هي المسائل التي ننظر
اليها لحظه تلو الاخرى للوقوف على كافه
الامكانيات المختلفه ومن ثم البدء
بالاستجابه بطريقه فعاله
للامور الانسانيه سعاده الامين العام
نشكركم على هذه المقابله ونشكركم على
افكاركم
ونشكركم على جهودكم الحميده وعلى مناشدتكم
من اجل الشعب السوداني للتوصلي الى السلام
والى العوده لجدت الصواب لوقف الحرب شكرا
وكذا مشاهدينا الكرام وصلنا الى نهايه هذا
اللقاء الخاص والحصري مع الامين العام
انطونيو
ونترك لكم الكلمه في دبي الان لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات